vamos a estudiar como la sangre recorre
desde nuestro corazón que dibujaremos
aquí todo el camino hasta la punta de
los dedos de los pies y voy a dibujar mi
pie por aquí para mostrarte a qué dedo
del pie me refiero a este de aquí
ahora empezaremos el viaje la sangre
tiene que salir del ventrículo izquierdo
a través de la arteria más grande del
cuerpo
esta es la aorta la aorta es muy muy
ancha y por eso es una arteria grande
aunque nos dibujaremos todas sus ramas
la aorta baja hasta mi vientre y se
ramifica hacia mi pierna izquierda y mi
pierna derecha sigamos solo la
ramificación de esta arteria de acá
arriba que va a la pierna izquierda esta
arteria es de menor tamaño tal vez
podemos llamar la arteria mediana
sigue bajando hasta nuestro tobillo ya
hemos recorrido bastante distancia hasta
nuestro tobillo y después se ramifica a
arterias de menor tamaño sigamos a la
arteria que va hacia mi pie supongamos
que es esta arteria de arriba llega mi
pie y es mucho más pequeña así que la
llamaremos arteria pequeña a partir de
ahí la sangre llegará a las arteriolas
que son aún más pequeñas es decir la
arteria pequeña se ramifica en ramas muy
muy pequeñitas y vamos a seguir el
camino de esta ramita de aquí y esta es
mi arte viola todas estas son las
distintas ramas por las que tenemos que
pasar hasta que finalmente llegamos a
unas ramas delgaditas dibujemos las muy
muy delgadas para que nos convenzamos
que son muy muy finas vamos a dibujar
cuatro de ellas por diversión estas
ramas se llaman capilares y se dirigen
hacia las células de mi dedo del pie
vamos a dibujar algunas células del dedo
del pie por aquí así podemos observar
que en efecto llegamos hasta acá y vamos
a escribir que estas son las células del
dedo del pie y después estas células
toman de la sangre todo lo que necesitan
tal vez necesitan glucosa o tal vez
oxígeno cualquier cosa que necesiten
por otra parte tiran sus desechos
es decir aportan desechos de dióxido de
carbono que la sangre necesita arrastrar
de regreso esto se vierte en lo que se
conoce como be nula esta p nula alimenta
a muchas otras células tal vez haya otra
vez nula por acá abajo quizás otra menos
la que llega desde otro dedo y poco a
poco se empiezan a reunir hasta llegar a
un conjunto de venas muy grandes tal vez
esta otra vena se vierte por acá otra
llega por acá y todas estas venas se
vierten en una vena enorme que llamamos
vena cava inferior
y esta es la vena más grande que trae la
sangre de la mitad inferior del cuerpo
de regreso al corazón también hay otra
vena por acá que se llama vena cava
superior que trae la sangre de los
brazos y la cabeza de regreso al corazón
estas dos venas la vena cava superior y
la vena cava inferior son las que llevan
la sangre al corazón pero de manera
general podemos considerar a todas estas
como venas
ahora regresemos a la parte de arriba y
empecemos con las arterias grandes y
medianas a estas dos arterias también se
les conoce con el nombre de arterias
elásticas y la razón del por qué las
llamamos arterias elásticas o una de las
razones correctas del por qué se llaman
así es que tienen una proteína en las
paredes de los vasos sanguíneos llamada
elastina estas arterias tienen mucha de
esta proteína elastina ahora bien
en la palabra el estilo o elástica que
son palabras similares pensamos en una
liga o en un globo y esta es la forma
más sencilla de pensar en ellas si
tenemos un vaso sanguíneo una de estas
grandes arterias la sangre que lleva
tiene una presión muy alta ya que el
corazón bombea con una presión elevada
entonces esta arteria es como un globo
si la vemos desde el exterior podemos
verla como un pequeño chorizo algo así
donde esta hinchada lo que pasa de la
primera a la segunda imagen es que la
energía de presión es decir el corazón
bombea sangre con mucha presión y por
supuesto hay energía en esa sangre
entonces la energía de presión se
convierte en energía elástica es decir
estamos transformando energía
no siempre lo pensamos de esta forma
pero es exactamente lo que pasa y cuando
conviertas la energía de presión en
energía elástica lo que realmente pasa
es que equilibramos las presiones altas
y esto es muy importante porque la
sangre viene de nuestras arterias tiene
una presión alta recuerda el sistema
arterial es un sistema con presión alta
y entonces esto tiene mucho sentido ya
que estas arterias grandes y medianas
son capaces de tratar con la presión sin
ningún problema por otra parte a las
arterias pequeñas ya las arteriolas se
les conoce con el nombre de arterias
musculares la razón del por qué las
llamamos así es que las paredes de las
arterias son muy musculosas en
específico hablamos de un músculo liso
es decir no es un músculo que tenemos en
el corazón o en los bíceps este es un
músculo liso que está en la pared de las
arterias
una vez más tenemos un vaso capilar como
este y debemos imaginar montones y
montones de músculo liso en el exterior
así que dibujemos las pequeñas bandas
del músculo liso si estas bandas deciden
contraerse y de apretarse entonces
podremos observarlas como un popote
pequeño es decir estos músculos pueden
estrecharse hasta parecer un popote
pequeño a este proceso se le conoce como
paso constricción paso se refiere a los
vasos sanguíneos y constricción se
refiere a contraer entonces
vasoconstricción es la contracción de
los vasos sanguíneos y con esto lo que
hacemos es incrementar la resistencia
esto es parecido a la gran resistencia
que existe al soplar a través de un
popote muy pero muy pequeño esa misma
idea ocurre por aquí ahora bien la
mayoría de esa resistencia y paso
constricción sucede a nivel
arteriolas por ello son muy especiales y
debemos recordar las de la sangre pasa
por los capilares
estos son los capilares también llamados
lechos capilares y la sangre seguirá su
camino será conectada por las venas y
finalmente por las venas
ahora bien la parte importante de las
venas es que tiene pequeñas válvulas y
esas válvulas aseguran de que la sangre
fluya en una dirección así que una cosa
importante son las válvulas y otra cosa
importante que debemos recordar es que
las venas son capaces de trabajar con
volúmenes grandes así que mientras que
en la parte arterial trabajamos con
presiones altas por acá abajo en la
parte venosa
trabajamos con volúmenes grandes
recordemos que aproximadamente dos
tercios de tu sangre en un momento dado
se encuentra en alguna venda o ve nuland